this guitar is with me for two reasons
which I'll explain both of which are to
do with the heading so what topic are we
in right now ignore that tell me what
topic overall we're in right now we we
we finished sequences in series recently
I say that again Taylor grab a verb
avere we have been differentiating so
far Treena metric functions the name of
the topic starts of the sea is calculus
right now calculus has more to it than
differentiation but earlier this year we
just started with simple polynomials we
add on a few rules like + 3 in
particular when things are multiplied
together used to UM differentiate them
we use the product rule product rule
when things are divided we use the
question on when you've got a function
of a function you use that chain or very
good
so we learnt all that but it was all to
do just with polynomials and then very
recently we expanded that as Tyler said
we looked at trigonometric functions
sine what's its derivative
pause cos what's its derivative negative
sign tan what's its derivative is x
squared X and then all of the variations
with product question and chain rule
okay now think back what was the most
recent after trig differentiation e to
the power of X so we're looking at
exponential functions right what's
special about the exponential function
its derivative is itself and that often
leads to some weed complexities with the
chain rule all that but that's unusual
no other functional family functions
does that ok you'd take a quadratic when
you differentiate e you get something
linear you take sine differentiates it
because you get the idea okay now we're
going to push further into this however
and this is now getting to this when was
the last time you really did logarithms
how long has it been it's been it's been
a while right like like at least a
couple of months is what I'm saying
okay and here's the thing you need to
know these backwards in order to do the
calculus with them and that's why I want
to show you what I spent like six months
of my life doing when I was well
actually ah I was almost exactly your
age because I picked up because they
guitar in my HSA yeah and I spent six
months of my life every single day
fifteen minute I'd spent doing this and
this is seriously
all I would do up and down for about 15
minutes until well why do you think I
only did 15 minutes yeah cuz my my
fingers started cramping and and all
bleeding right now here's the thing
right i I've never ever played a piece
of music that required me to use in
sequence and F and then F sharp and then
a G and then a G sharp and then an a in
in that order and then back down
in fact I hardly ever even play the G
major chord that's better like this
because who plays in acoustic any kind
of guitar here okay you know this is not
the play way to play a G major how do
you play a G major come on show me show
me fingers yeah it's hilarious it's like
air guitars how'd it look
you play it like this right in a much
easy for maybe maybe maybe like this so
you can get this uh small anyway you get
the idea now why would I do this and
plant an unnecessary way for exactly the
same reason that we're gonna have a look
at the rules the laws for how logarithms
work you need to know them backwards and
forwards so that when you're actually
playing the song so when you're doing
calculus with these things you're not
thinking hard about where on earth to my
fingers go what's the law that helps me
change the power of the thing you need
to have that at the back of your mind
okay so that's the first reason I'm not
gonna tell you the second reason yeah
I'm gonna see if you can work it out
I'll just leave that there as a prop if
you haven't already made the heading
state please do so and now I'm going to
first ask for your help underneath this
we're gonna think about our log laws log
laws and I am hoping I am hoping deep in
your repressed memory you've got some of
the log laws still in your mind even
some really simple ones so here so I'm
gonna ask you four I'm gonna ask you
four if you want to go for the hard
version you can give this to me
algebraically I'll give you an example
of what I mean and algebraic index law
whoops
this this is an index law and it stated
I'll come to you first right it stated
generally right it's like for any a for
any M for any end you can say this it's
probably bit easier to say just
numerically like for example 2 cubed
times 2 to the power of 5 equals to the
power of 8 okay because you've added
those indices okay so I'm gonna ask you
to see how many log laws you can
actually give to me just from memory
let's see how we go Saran you told me
you had one log so is the a down the
body the a is the base and then yep log
a set again M times n just before you go
on is this is this right is this right
okay
just before we are just before I confirm
it cuz we're writing this all down
together sir a actually it's a perfect
example because if you have a look up
the top here right well this this is the
reverse of this right when you're
multiplying powers or I should say when
you're multiplying numbers are the same
base and different powers you add the
powers right logs our Exponential's in
reverse so instead of multiplication
turning into addition what do you see
here what are the operations addition
turns into location happy okay good you
can get an easy one for free if you give
me the reverse of this one any takers
who can give me the reverse of this one
now you already give me one that's good
someone else
[Music]
okay so just before we all write this
just for the sake of it for this one it
didn't matter because addition you can
do in any order for this one I'm going
to change it just to make it a little
easier for your brains to remember well
do it alphabetically so if we make that
M and that n okay as thank you said
we're gonna get a new log it's going to
be division first divided by second okay
M over N okay we've got two down
who can give me another one Sophie we're
about to find out that one right fine
all right so so this again and then
here's the point right it doesn't matter
what the numbers are
yeah if you're adding logs that have the
same base in this case it's C in this
case it's a it still works the same
that's why these are laws that's why
they're useful that's okay let's um just
rewind for a second we can still turn
this into a different one we can still
turn this into a different one this is a
base safe right suppose I didn't want
the base I should get rid of this
suppose I didn't want the base to be
seen what could I do with this any
takers
log someone told me you can do it I'll
give you a big clue it's got one of
these in it it's a dream L so if you
don't try and redeem yourself yeah okay
get rid okay hold on one second hold on
just hold that thought
Aditya sorry you with us you did some
good work up key being efficient by the
way you should be writing this with me
okay go ahead
where am I putting the a do you want to
tag yeah I've got some volunteers who
are willing to take Tyler go ahead log
base 10 hey what am I gonna put next log
base 10 see does it have to be 10 so 10
is a good number because our calculator
has a log base 10 button on it but it
doesn't have to be 10 so long as these
numbers match it's okay so instead of
saying 10 + 10 I could just call it
anything Salons is consistent right why
don't I call it um what I call it X is
that okay what do we call this one
change of base law okay very good
all right let me let me throw some other
ones actually I'll nudge you in the
right direction okay
log base that's an earth base a of a
what is that come on it isn't it's one
right Sophie Sean you want to give
another one Shea go ahead
aha very good so this one here this one
here is actually a souped up special
version of the top one right does that
does that make sense because look you're
adding a whole bunch of them which means
you multiply it that's a power okay good
so if you don't give me another one
we'll find out that's okay
Ln bracket is that what you said yep
equals one okay this is this is a law
can someone tell me which of the walls
on the board is it closest to it's um
it's this one
why does it look different well
different number but also this is a
notation we haven't talked about at
least today what does that mean it's log
base e of e which is it's just a
specialized version of this amazing okay
it isn't another one log base of B of
one okay this is an important one if you
haven't got this phone around already
now just next to this by the way and
it's helpful maybe to do this for more
than one of them there is an equivalent
index law for this right
what's the index law that has a zero in
a have a think what be the equivalent of
this I'll give you a clue it starts with
a be something ^ be them have zero that
equals one right that's same deal here
okay what would be the index equation
that comes with this that second last
one I'll give you a clue see that base
there becomes the base here right so
what should the base be here
I write e ^ is it e to the power B C the
power of one equals a which is the same
as a to the power of 1 equals Hey okay
now I'm pretty happy with this set the
change of base law and the power law are
sometimes the ones that people forget
okay what I want us to do is get
comfortable again with using these